and the male pattern of antisocial
behavior is a lot more physically
violent the female pattern of antisocial
behavior is reputation destruction
and it scales on the internet physical
aggression doesn't right it's limited
and i'm not saying it's not serious it
can obviously be
mortally serious right it's serious
but it does characterize it a small
minority of men female anti-social
behavior which is almost never discussed
there's a large research literature on
it
because people have wondered you know
that if you look at boys and girls for
example
two-year-olds i mentioned them some
two-year-olds are aggressive and that's
by nature mostly
okay so they kick hit bite and steal in
groups of two-year-olds now they're not
very harmful because they're two
but if it doesn't if it isn't socialized
it turns into conduct disorder and that
turns into antisocial criminal behavior
that's what happens
this podcast exists because i love
talking to people and i love going deep
the purpose is to plant seeds of
inspiration we enter a space of
vulnerability and relatability and what
you realize is that we are so much more
alike than we are different to quote
ramdas we're all just walking each other
home and this show is just one step i'm
danica patrick and i'm pretty intense
today on the show is someone that i am
so so excited about i have been
listening to
his talks and his information for so
long
his name is dr jordan peterson he's a
professor of psychology a clinical
psychologist
and author of best-selling books 12
rules for life an antidote to chaos and
now he has beyond order 12 more rules
for life
so
clearly we need a lot of rules for life
because there's a life is really
challenging and that's a lot of what we
talked about is just how hard it is how
complicated it is and then we get into
self-awareness which i think is just a
huge thing to become self-aware of
something going on facing i think we all
want to get better but it's a matter of
how do we figure out where we need to
get better where are our blind spots
he's a fascinating human if you've never
heard of him
get ready he's a straight down the
barrel kind of guy and i think you're
gonna like this
wow hi jordan how are you hi danika how
are you doing
i'm good eh
i've got some uh i have uh i have
relatives that live in canada so i'm
familiar with the canadian accent i love
the canadians
and people really do say a all the time
oh yeah they do
yeah and a boot that's really true well
i can't hear that
[Laughter]
sounds like a bout to me
people say it isn't
thank you for the invitation oh
thank you for doing it this is um
i don't think there's been an interview
that i have been more excited about
or prepared as much
and my preparation is not really like
hasn't been just all the like since i
knew we were doing this
i have been paying attention to your
work and listening to you and watching
youtube videos for
years and years and i just think that
you're brilliant i think that you are
you have such an incredible scope one of
the things that's so amazing is how you
are able to
layer in so many different
sources whether it's
religion
or mythology or psychology
and you just blend them also
comprehensively when you answer a
question
and i just i just think it's it's
brilliant how how are you able how are
you able to take all of those sources
and blend them together so smooth
well
my mind works in a theoretical way i
would say i was talking with two
psychologists yesterday stephen pinker
and jonathan height and
height
seems to think like me he he has a kind
of a master theory in some sense and
then he just plugs things into it
whereas pinker
remembers facts he has an amazing memory
he's he's like a he's like an
encyclopedia and i'm not like that like
facts themselves don't really stick with
me
i have a theory about things and i just
plug new pieces of information into it
all the time and it's one big story
and so i kind of know the story i guess
that's the right and that's how i think
and so
if a topic elicits part of that theory
which i've been writing about and
lecturing about for you know 30 years
then i have something to say about it i
think it's i think it's something like
what jazz musicians do
they have all sorts of riffs and tricks
that they have stored up and then they
can improvise with them
as needs be and that seems to be how i
think and how i lecture
well i'm always trying to build this
theory and to cover new territory with
it and to make it more comprehensive
well what's the what's that theory
well
i suppose in essence it's it's it's a
theory about
the story that we
look at the world through
first of all the theory is that we do
look at the world through a story
and
you know people are very very attracted
to stories right children will beg for a
story
so there's something very
particular about stories that compel us
and i mean it's odd if you think about
it we'll pay to go watch a story
it doesn't matter if it hurts our
feelings doesn't matter it makes us
anxious or upsets us any of those things
it doesn't matter
we're still so enthralled by it that
we'll go
expose ourselves to it so stories must
be extremely useful to us unless you
just write that off as mere
entertainment which i don't think is
very smart
and
a story is about going from
where you are to somewhere better
usually
and then about the catastrophes that
might befall you along the way
the unexpected occurrences and how those
might resolve and
how that might change you the way you
look at the world the way you interact
with other people either for the better
or the worse better if it's a comedy and
worse if it's a tragedy
and so i've been trying to unpack
what a story is
a simple story is just a child might
tell it
i went to kindergarten today
you know
more complicated story is i went to
kindergarten today but on the way a mean
dog barked at me and i got real upset
and i thought maybe i'd go home but i
decided to continue
then you pat the child on the head and
say well that was a good decision
right that you stuck with your course
despite the fact that you got way late
by something frightening
and so the first story is a i called it
a normal story in my first book in the
second story a revolutionary story
and so
exodus in the old testament is a
revolutionary story
right because
the israelites leave the jews leave
the tyranny egypt
and escape into freedom but then
everything falls apart
into chaos
and then at least in principle they find
their way again and move forward
it's a very powerful story
how can we know
because so many of these stories whether
they're from
you know ancient egypt or
like i went to egypt earlier this year
and hearing the stories about
uh osiris and isis and horus and all of
these different stories but that or
religious even from time that jesus was
around when they you know put you know
wrote these stories down
many many decades later how how do we
know
if the story is real because memory is
poor
well
i think
that's a very very complicated problem
obviously i mean
some forms of truth
are factual
scientific truths are factual other
sorts of truths you act out
and you see if they work
and so
they're true
in the sense that an arrow is true when
it flies or someone's heart is true
right there's lots of variations of the
idea of truth and
so
christian's story posits a
ideal at its center
and that's
the story of christ and
and everything about him
and
the truth of that is to be
discovered in action as far as i can
tell acting it out it's a
target for emulation and imitation
it's not so much a description of
objective reality although it might also
be that but
and so
to believe it is to act it out a kind of
ethic
and part of what christianity is is a
discussion about what constitutes the
ideal
that we should all act out that unites
us around that ideal and it also
structures our expectations because
we're disappointed
in ourselves
and in other people
whenever we don't manifest that ideal
right
your conscience bothers you you feel
guilty you feel ashamed because you're
not
putting forward your ideal self and that
ideal you know people have been trying
to sort out what that ideal is for a
very long time okay so certainly the
egyptians you talked about part of their
ideal was isis
horus osiris they all represented
different elements of
existence osiris was the god of the
state
essentially he was willfully blind and
was defeated by his evil brother seth
that happens to states all the time that
malevolent forces take them over when
they're willfully blind
and horus
horus is the egyptian eye
and everyone knows that symbol still
which is quite amazing given that it's
thousands of years old and
horus is the god who pays attention so
the egyptians worshiped attention as the
force that revitalized the old state
and it's brilliant it's different
than thought
attention right attention is
reception
it's being willing to see what's in
front of your eyes
and so the egyptians figured out took
them a long long time that there was
something divine about the capacity to
pay attention something that would
redeem the blind state
so you know all of us are inheritors of
a cultural tradition
it's functional
in the u.s that's embodied i suppose in
the constitution
but the constitution is dead except in
so far as it's
embodied in living people who are paying
attention
right so
the egyptian pharaoh was a combination
of osiris and horus it was brilliant
idea
so that meant that he was
the tradition that had founded the state
plus the capacity to pay attention um
and renew the state yeah yeah and they
figured out that that was the central
idea the central element of
appropriate sovereignty
wow
right because you might say well would
it be brute force would it be power
there's lots of accusations about that
today
cultural institutions are basically
predicated on power that's wrong
it's it's a it's a it's terrible way to
think it's i mean they they are
predicated on power when they become
corrupt
but you know everyone you know who's
corrupt uses power
no one that no one that
is behaving according to the ideal
uses force to get their way and it's not
very efficient anyways
makes you unpopular
it makes you a target
it's unstable socially
it's unsophisticated doesn't even work
well for children doesn't work well for
animals for that matter often um
so it might not maybe it's not even that
this whether the story is right or not
it's a
maybe more of a guideline it's more
it's more
archetypal kind of
uh
stories that help guide us and maybe
doesn't even matter if they're real what
matters is that we're using them to be
better
to have good ideals too
real is a tricky business in some sense
you know because
abstract things
can be more real than concrete things
like
numbers for example are very abstract
but they're real enough so that if you
can manipulate them you can change the
world
and you know if we if you read deep
literature
a
deep literature is
in some sense a distillation of
character
right i mean no one would want to read
just about your day if you described
every detail right you sort of pull out
what's interesting and relevant and
and and essential
and so these stories are in some sense
essential
and so they're true in that they're
abstractions that's how i look at it now
that leaves open
the relationship between them and what
we would normally consider historical
truth
and there's tremendous amount of debate
about that i certainly don't have the
answer to that but
you know there's an idea for example
common idea that christ is the king of
kings
well so you imagine that
you abstract out of people what would
make someone noble
right so you look at noble features
across a bunch of
across a assortment of different people
and you think well there i could make a
noble character and then you take all
those noble characters and you take the
most noble element of them and you say
that's a king then you take a group of
kings and you say what's most kingly
you abstract out that
right so that's that's part of the idea
now people like carl jung and c.s lewis
believed that
they believed that christ acted out that
archetype that king of kings and so
there was a union between
the historical reality and the
abstraction
and so
you know we don't know what would happen
if an ideal person came into existence
perhaps nothing i mean we don't know do
we
but
is that maybe not even the point i've
really thought about this is that not
the point
maybe even of being here in this
human existence do we need is
do we need the polarity do we need the
sides do we need the contrast
like if there was an ideal person
does that even work here
that's a good question i mean we do seem
disappointed when people don't live up
to the ideal that we expect but by the
same token we tend to love people
even sometimes for their faults
certainly despite them
so
ideal guides us along and judges us all
the time
you know you you work towards a better
self at least to some degree you have
some conceptualization of that you're
excited when that works out and
disappointed when it doesn't
certainly with people you love although
you do accept them in some sense the way
they are
you're disappointed
when they aren't all they could be as
far as you're concerned that's
particularly true probably a family
members
perhaps that's particularly true of
parents in relationship to their
children
you know and that's a funny question you
know when you love somebody do you love
the ideal they could be or do you love
them or both perhaps
because you want to encourage them you
want to have have them grow towards
something that's better
and you know we we're so attracted to
um
vulnerability and vulnerability implies
perhaps a shortcoming right like
something that's just not not ideal
and
that's a connection vulnerability is a
point of connection
so what if we don't have any of that
yeah well i guess in some sense that's a
justification for vulnerability isn't it
well how would we have connection then
where does where does connection come
from
well that's a good question we wouldn't
be the creatures we are without our
vulnerabilities
that's for sure you really see that in
children
you know and and the fact that they're
vulnerable doesn't make you less care
for them less far
quite the contrary yeah but it's i think
it's in adults too i mean whether it's
something that i've shared something
that you've shared about your struggles
like
i think it's in the vulnerability that
we create relatability
and
you know the connection point
yeah it's it's certainly that in part i
mean we also look to each other for
for inspiration but i often that comes
as a consequence of overcoming
vulnerabilities
one of the things that i think i have
had the most struggle with and this
comes to a lot of what you talk about
about you know being better and choosing
you know addressing things that are
difficult and
it comes in the form of self-awareness i
found self-awareness to be incredibly
hard
it's not that i don't want to get better
it's that sometimes i don't know how to
get better i can't see myself so i have
to use people and experiences and
patterns
to discover those things so
how can how can one create more
self-awareness i think you got it
exactly right there
i think you got it right a lot of that's
generated
as a consequence of interacting with
other people
i mean you know you're you're limited by
your blind spots and your ignorance
and so you can try to overcome that but
sometimes you don't even know what it is
and in my latest book and beyond order
i think it's uh is it the first chapter
yes it's the first chapter talk about
the necessity for social interactions
for sanity
right because
in some ways you think of yourself as
maintaining
good mental health if you're well
organized internally if your psyche is
in
proper order but
it's a lot easier
to act in a way that other people find
acceptable
and then to take your cues from them
and that helps keep you organized and
together so you know when your jokes are
funny and you know when you're not
contributing enough to a conversation or
maybe you're contributing too much or
you're not pulling your weight or other
people clue you into that sort of thing
all the time so
part of what keeps people sane is
healthy social dynamic and the ability
to pay attention to cues and that might
be particularly true for children i was
reading a book the other day
i fortunately don't remember the name of
it i didn't read much of it but
it was written by an anthropologist who
spent some time in more tribal societies
watching how they raised children
well in some sense they didn't
the children went off and played
and so they socialized each other
and
that's
a good example of how
sanity emerges from social interactions
is that is are you implying that that's
better that that dynamic is better i
know that your thoughts on raising
children include like
you know as few rules as possible as
little discipline as possible which
seems i wouldn't say as little
discipline but rules
okay you know there well there's a good
rule for rules which is don't multiply
rules beyond necessity
because bad rules drive out respect for
good rules
and the cost of a rule is enforcement
so every time you add a rule well you
add the necessity of enforcement
so
there are minimal you know you want a
minimal set of necessary rules
and then you need to enforce them but
generally
children socialize each other there's
there's very good evidence for that
apart from this book which as i said i
had just begun to read
um children who are
aggressive at two
so there's a subset of children who are
quite aggressive at two they are
aggressive by nature by all appearances
um
most of them are socialized by the age
of four
and if they're socialized by then they
develop peer relationships that are
strong and then that carries them along
their peer relationships so in some
sense the job of a parent is to
socialize children well enough so that
they can have friends
how do you do that
well
one of the rules i laid out in the first
book i wrote was don't let your children
do anything that makes you dislike them
and that's i suppose part of
self-awareness i mean you might say well
i'd never dislike my child it's like
yeah right
come on
come on now that doesn't mean you don't
love them although you know now and then
you might feel that you don't love them
too
but certainly
you're going to dislike them momentarily
for things that they're doing or not
doing well
you know if you don't like them what
makes you think someone else will
and then you might say well that's just
me you know that's just you you're just
one person well
you're the closest thing to a
representative of the social community
that they have so they're stuck with you
and then i would also say well it'd
probably be better if there were two of
you
you know
father and a mother
because then you can
try to make sure that both of you add up
to one sane person so the child can
interact with that one sane person but
you know it's definitely the case that
i mean i've seen children who don't have
anyone to play with because they don't
know how to play
they're not socialized it's horrible
and they fall farther and farther behind
all the time because
do you think that falls on is that is
that a parent thing is that maybe being
a household
of you know not having a mom and a dad
there children who are fatherless do
worse there's no doubt about that and no
one likes to say that but the
research evidence is crystal clear
and it's hardly surprising i don't know
why anyone would find that surprising
first of all
it's too much work
to raise children by yourself especially
if you have to work
so in that case you're not going to
raise them by yourself anyways you're
going to have other people help you but
you know it's likely the case that the
nuclear family is the minimum necessary
social arrangement for raising children
and it's it's possibly not sufficient
you know we also don't know what's
happened to children because they don't
have very many siblings anymore
and siblings really in some sense
socializing they certainly help take the
narcissism out of you
right because siblings they don't let
each other get away with
being
being narcissistic essentially they're
they're very very uh unhappy about
special attention
so we don't know how many
children children have to have around in
order to be socialized properly
i suspect we're airing on the side of
not enough now
and probably not enough for parents
does it
it seems but is it the case that
narcissism is becoming more and more and
more common
i really don't know it's very very
difficult to answer questions like that
because we just don't have reliable
measures across
generations
you know it isn't obvious to me that
young people today are more narcissistic
than young people were in the 60s
so you know
it wasn't obvious to me when i was
teaching university that the students
were more narcissistic than they were
when i started teaching
but but like i said fundamentally it's
it's it's hard to get an accurate
measure of something like narcissism and
then to track it over decades you don't
even know if the measure itself shifts
i do believe that they're
that people are more lonesome than they
were they're more socially isolated but
you know
that's also very difficult to
determine yeah i'm loath to make
intergenerational comparisons you know
because
every generation thinks that this
current young generation is worse than
any generation that's ever existed and
it's like when you when you grow up and
you listen to your you know your parents
listen to your music and they're like
this stuff's awful and then that
continues on every generation like that
stuff's awful that the kid or listen
kids are listening to
it's like no matter what there's always
this idea that oh it's the worst than
ever
and so maybe that leads to that question
which is
what is better and what is worse than
ever
right now in our culture
i guess it depends to some degree on
your scale
so globally
in terms of economic
uh and absolute economic security
it's better than it's ever been by a
huge margin for everyone
so
there's a much smaller proportion of
people who are without food and water
and sanitary facilities
technology and education
and immunization and health care and
basic living standard
and it's it's and that's a huge amount
of that's
developed in the last 30 years
and almost all of it has developed in
the last 150
despite the fact that the population has
exploded to a tremendous degree and so
from the perspective of absolute
privation things are better than they
ever have been
in the west
well that's hard to say too isn't that i
mean there's all sorts of opportunities
that there weren't the technological
explosion has produced a tremendous
increment in wealth in some ways i mean
you have more computational power in
your
phone than
nasa used to send people to the moon and
back
and it's basically free now it's not
free but fundamentally the cost is
plummeted to such a degree that
so and we have this tremendous
communications technology
there's a kind of instability i think
that wasn't there
20 years ago
and i think it's a consequence of rapid
technological change
it seems to me and that's possibly
because i'm old
like i have a hard time keeping up now
and i was really
just on the edge of
the generation that became familiar with
computers many people my age never
became familiar with computers not
really
i did but i spent a lot of time and i
needed to because of my job and i spent
a lot of time
making myself technologically
able let's say
but
my health is impaired now so that's a
problem but i find it difficult to keep
up there's so many things to keep up
with and changes take place so fast
just as you adapt to one thing
another thing comes along and it's like
that with everything your computer
changes your refrigerator changes your
car changes right in front of your eyes
it's updating all the time and
so your knowledge is continually
outdated
so you you know you work very hard to
develop expertise with something and all
of a sudden it's completely different
i found that very frustrating with
microsoft word
you know i really knew the programs and
then they changed the menu it's like
well i spent like 10 years practicing
how to use that i really knew it it's
like well now the menus changed and so
all that knowledge is gone and so
and
we have no idea what this intense focus
on social media
is doing to everyone but particularly to
young people
i mean can you imagine
that
nothing you ever did with as a teenager
could be forgotten
i look can you imagine that god
i mean i also look at it from the from
the perspective of hiding but you know
hiding behind the phone and i live in a
world where people have said horrible
things about me on the internet and on
social media yeah that's funny yeah it's
so fun i know you have a lot of
experience with that but i don't know
them so i can write that off to they
don't even know me right but now this
happens in school and a kid can read
this and and they they're in class with
that person or they they have a locker
near them and they're like is that true
then and i think that that is such a
dangerous and horrible thing for a kid
to have to deal with i very much
empathize with kids today and social
media
and just
you know we haven't even talked about
pure body image and just pure looks i
mean you don't know what anybody looks
like anymore
through social media and filters anymore
either but but definitely from at least
like a
acceptance standpoint
when people say things
yeah well one of the things i've been
concerned about
is that
so there's a there's a female pattern of
antisocial behavior and there's a male
pattern of antisocial behavior
and the male pattern of antisocial
behavior is a lot more physically
violent
the female pattern of antisocial
behavior is reputation destruction
yeah
yeah and it scales on the internet
see physical aggression doesn't right
right what can you do right it's limited
and i'm not saying it's not serious it
can obviously be
mortally serious right it's serious
but it does characterize it a small
minority of men especially
consistently
but female antisocial behavior which is
almost never discussed there's a large
research literature on it
because people have wondered you know
that if you look at boys and girls for
example
two-year-olds i mentioned them some
two-year-olds are aggressive and that's
by nature mostly
okay so they kick hit bite and steal
in groups of two-year-olds now they're
not very harmful because they're two
but if it doesn't if it isn't socialized
it turns into conduct disorder and that
turns into antisocial criminal behavior
that's what happens
so most people who are criminal by the
time they're 18 were aggressive when
they were two and weren't socialized
okay so now most of those aggressive
two-year-olds are boys
if you define aggression by hitting
kicking stealing and biting
but the reputation destruction that
starts early with girls and that's their
form of anti-social behavior and you
know
we don't know what political
manifestation female anti-social
behavior will produce
because
the
complete immersement of men and women in
the political realm is new
but for to think that it'll be nothing
well you have to be a complete bloody
fool to think that because obviously the
dark side of men has a dark political
edge why wouldn't the dark side of women
have a dark political edge
so
i know you know there's no discussion
about that at all to speak of
but i can't help seeing it i see it i
think that's the reputation destruction
that's characteristic of social media
seems to be i mean i saw
when girls went after my daughter in
particular when she was a teenager
bullying on on social media they use
reputation destruction and it can be
unbelievably vicious while you said
you've been attacked plenty online
wow huh so do you so the social network
being as it is i mean well we look at
you know chrissy teigen or people like
that i mean
women
have definitely been on the fire for
things that have happened
on social
social media platforms
hmm i wonder if it's more men than women
then
well that's a good question that would
be a good place to start the research
like i don't know who now it's also
possible that
you know there's a large proportion of
men who use reputation destruction too
online
so
i wouldn't say that this is something
limited to women by any stretch of the
imagination but i do know that those two
patterns of antisocial behavior exist
so and that one doesn't scale so that is
a relevant issue
so
you were talking about asked about body
image or commented on body image too you
know we could talk about that a little
bit if you'd like yeah absolutely a lot
of people think that that's a
consequence of social pressure
body image trouble and i don't think
there's any evidence for that by the way
really yeah well a lot of
so
women are more likely to have body image
problems than men
okay so that's the first thing
so and that's likely because
body morphology is more important in
mating choice
for women than it is for men
men tend to prefer women who show signs
of fertility that's associated with
youth
and symmetry
so symmetry is very very important as as
a marker of beauty so we tend to see
symmetrical faces as beautiful waist to
hip ratio 0.68 that seems to be
relatively standard culturally
regardless of body size
and that's also that's associated with
cardiovascular health and with fertility
and so
there's an ideal
idealized ideal female
morphology and any deviation from that
causes upset and women are more prone to
negative emotion than men not anger by
the way
that's that's a tougher one
but
anxiety and pain related emotions women
are more sensitive to those than men
maybe because they're smaller and
life is more dangerous to them and they
have to be more threat sensitive
maybe because they take care of infants
and so you know one question i've never
discussed this i don't think on online
women become more sensitive to negative
emotion than men when they hit puberty
not before
and it never goes away after that
right so it's a permanent transformation
even after menopause just like
yeah well the men and women get more
stable emotionally as they get older but
the difference between men and women
doesn't seem to attenuate
and so i've now women became sex become
sexually vulnerable at puberty so that
might be one reason why they would be
more sensitive to danger right
yeah right i mean there's plenty of
places in the world where you wouldn't
walk alone
sure right there's there's plenty of
places where walking alone would make
you a valid target even
right right right and i would say that's
probably more the norm for human
societies than the exception
you know we assume that our relatively
safe
environments are
normal they're not they took a lot of
work to get safe
like so much work that it's almost
incomprehensible
there's just so many things we take for
granted that make up that safety
that that are invisible because because
it's mostly there
but
i also wonder possibly if women's
nervous systems are optimized
for
the
woman child dyad and not for the woman
so imagine that well if you have a baby
you're definitely more vulnerable
right right and so perhaps your nervous
system should reflect that because
you're the one making the decisions
and you know because women are more
prone to anxiety disorders and
depression than men that seems true
cross culture and it goes along with
that sensitivity to negative emotion you
think what's the advantage to that
because it causes a lot of suffering oh
it's no yeah it's terrible terrible it's
terrible
i would love to talk more about anxiety
when we get through this topic but it's
a it's it's crippling for people yes
absolutely well it's also a good promote
predictor of marital instability because
higher levels of negative emotion
predict well unhappiness so obviously
marital stability and or
merely instability but
it's certainly possible that women's
nervous systems adult women's are are
optimized for the for the child for the
infant mother diet
i mean why would we expect it to be
other than that you know because a baby
is so unbelievably dependent
sure sure so so and and
well so there's all sorts of adaptations
that have to take place to that you have
to be more cautious once you have an
infant especially one under one years
old but even you know under three
under five for that matter
so then it comes into saying what what
is the point and so if anxiety comes in
if that is a
natural
um a biological shift once you hit
puberty yeah
for
precaution for self
as well as child yeah then let's then we
we know all the negative i mean the
negative side effects seem very loud but
what are the positives what are the
positives of anxiety well you're more
likely to stay away from danger
right you're more sensitive to danger
more sensitive to threat you're more
sensitive perhaps to the danger of
predatory men
you know and that's not trivial it if
if you have a step parent you're 100
times more likely to be abused
100 times yes
yes
wow yeah well you know it's it's hard to
raise kids
they're biologically related to you you
know that's an additional bond
especially if you're there right from
the beginning right and it's very tricky
to negotiate a child adult relationship
especially if you're an interloper and
maybe the kid doesn't like you or vice
versa and there's plenty of rivalry for
attention
and there's plenty of rivalry for
attention within families
so
yeah so while the upside to anxiety is
that
it protects you from danger
that's its purpose
to me it feels like though that there
are these patterns and and maybe
maybe it happens when they're very young
that they can feel the parent's anxiety
and it well you're saying that it
doesn't get triggered until puberty but
it feels like something that loops for
people
oh look it can go out of control
constantly
it definitely
that's a very good observation
a lot of a lot of the the
the conditions we think about as mental
illnesses are looping phenomena right so
for example imagine you get depressed so
you well then you start to isolate
yourself
so then you don't have any social
contact so then you get more depressed
then you isolate yourself more right and
anxiety is like that too imagine you
start to get afraid of going outside
so you don't go outside well then you
get more afraid of going outside you get
more anxious and lots of things loop
like that and get out of control
or you drink alcohol and then you find
out that if you have a drink when you're
hung over it fixes it
well then then the cause the cause
becomes the cure
that's not good that's a positive
feedback loop too and lots of things
lots of things that go out of control
are positive feedback loops like that
what's actually happening in the body
that creates the looping
well with anxiety um breath irregularity
can do it
so because it changes the chemical
sure and exacerbate it because it
changes the chemical composition of your
blood
so
one of the things that therapists do to
deal with panic attacks in particular is
to have people breathe regularly and you
can do that for relaxation exercise too
so
that's where meditation comes in where
they say it's so beneficial
possibly yeah yeah it takes a lot of
practice so
so people are less prone to do that but
yeah i also find that with yoga even i
don't know if you've ever done yoga
before but it it almost to me feels like
it feels so good because you breathe so
slow and long
and controlled and there there aren't
that many physical activities that you
do where there's like such a focus on
breath
um but breath being a really powerful
tool for a lot of things yeah well it's
pretty fundamental you do it what many
many times a minute
it's important to get it right another
thing that you talk about a lot as we're
talking about these loops and patterns
is uh
how you can actually become aware of
the things that hold you back or as
you've talked about so many times the
monstrance died like how
do you actually become aware of that
because again i think self-awareness is
half the battle really maybe even more
in my mind because i think a lot of
people by nature i think they want to be
better i think they just don't always
know how or have the examples or have
the awareness so
what do you do what can you do to
to sort of cultivate that awareness and
cultivate that ability to be able to see
the things that are going on in your
life that are holding you back
and fall into a loop or a pattern well
i have a practical answer for that if if
you want to get better um
i developed a writing set of writing
exercises with my colleagues
right so there's well we have two
exercises one's a personality test and
so
for self-awareness that can be really
useful
in fact if you take it with your partner
you get a couple's report
so it'll tell you
10
10 aspects of your personality clumped
into five factors extroversion so how
social you are and how positive how
bubbly how enthusiastic how assertive
how talkative that's all extraversion
neuroticism that's negative emotion
almost all of them anger irritability
fear guilt shame despair disgust
disgust is a little unique but all the
negative emotions clump together and
people differ in their susceptibility to
that
agreeableness women are more agreeable
than men by quite a substantial margin
it's associated with compassion and
politeness
and so disagreeable people they're more
blunt
they'll tell you they're less conflict
avoidance yes no doubt no doubt no doubt
yeah it'd be interesting to take the
personality test and see where you fall
because my suspicions are that for a
woman you're quite disagreeable and that
that's not a that's not a
insult by the way agreeableness is quite
a weird dimension because there are
marked positive and negative attributes
all along the entire dimension
so disagreeable people if they're really
disagreeable they can be callous and
unkind and cruel and antisocial
um but very very agreeable people can be
dependent and
um and and over nurturing and devouring
you know on the on the
all never let you go end of the spectrum
right so that's agreeableness
conscientiousness that's orderliness and
industriousness it's the best predictor
of lifetime success apart from general
cognitive ability which is iq
essentially and openness which is
creativity
and it's associated with um
well interest in diverse activities and
novelty aesthetic experiences
and interest in ideas
philosophical ideas and so
um you do a podcast you're probably
pretty high in openness oh yeah i am
very high in openness is this the future
what's it called this is called
understand myself
and if you do it you get a report for
you and if your partner does it you get
a report for them and both of you and
the reason we did that that's a
relatively new innovation by the way
the reason we did that is because
it's not easy for people to understand
each other and they often feel that
their partner is being arbitrary so for
example my parents my mother is very
extroverted and my father is quite
introverted especially he's low in
enthusiasm
and so my mom would just as soon be out
with people having fun all the time
but that exhausts my dad
and introverts get exhausted by social
interactions i think they're more
they're more their niche is one-on-one
and maybe being in nature
whereas extroverts they want to be in
society and they tell jokes and they
smile and they blink more and there's
all sorts of things that go along with
it
but if you're extroverted and your
partner's introverted you've got a
problem because you're always going to
be wanna gonna be out and about and that
energizes you and when you're not with
people that is you're gonna be unhappy
or you're gonna be not happy not unhappy
because that's neuroticism but you're
not going to be happy the positive
emotion is going to go away and so how
do you bridge that gap
that's how you are it's not some
arbitrary decision it's built into you
and so if you really diverge in
extroversion well that's a problem if
you're both really high in negative
emotion
you're going to be setting yourself off
the two of you off all the time
right so and as i said that higher
levels of nauticism are associated with
marital unhappiness so if you're both
high in neuroticism that might be the
one dimension where you don't want to be
like your partner if you're if it's high
right for someone who's high in
neuroticism they might really like to
have a stable uh a stable partner who's
who's less
threat sensitive
so
and then agreeableness well agreeable
people they're easy to get along with
their conflict avoidant but they can be
pushovers and so if your partner's
disagreeable and you're agreeable it's
going to be hard for you to stand your
ground because you're going to get run
over
so awareness comes through actually
wanting it well there's well there's
that but also also understanding to some
degree understanding what the
differences are like i thought my
daughter was more disagreeable than she
is when she took my test she took the
test and it showed that she was higher
negative emotion than i thought and so
what i saw as
combative
was reactive anxiety
and that was really helpful to me
because i thought it was combative it
wasn't
so and
i thought i'd be able to tell that but i
couldn't
so people high negative emotion can be
irritable and so that looks like
combativeness but it's defensive
disagreeable people can be more
predatory they're out to get what they
want they want to win you know and
that's different
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the subscribe button